what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today I'm going
to be telling you the truth about Sarah
so
um
there's been a lot of controversy this
week and a lot of people have had my
name in their mouth
and I just think I owe it to myself to
be able to tell the truth because at the
end of the day on this channel we tell
the truth no matter what and I just
think that if people are gonna talk and
talk and talk about me I have a right to
defend myself I've right to say what
actually goes on
and I'm so tired of these people coming
at me for everything and it's like you
can't even tell the truth about anything
anymore because people are pandering to
Their audience
um so one thing that people have accused
me of is grifting and regurgitating you
just regurgitate what you hear you just
griffed and you're just pandering to an
audience
it's like I can't have my own thoughts
or opinions without them believing that
those are not my thoughts and opinions
um on top of that
people will say that
I'm doing this for money
and that it's all about money to me
where do I begin
a couple months ago
I made a friend in England
um
and this friend and I were best friends
like we we were literally so close
um her and I would go like when we first
got to England and this is before the
whole YouTube stuff like she was there
literally before I had any ounce of Fame
to my name and she honestly saw me
grinding and trying so hard
to get this YouTube channel off the
ground right so
I'm in England and mind you I'm alone
you know my family is in the U.S as you
guys know I have nine siblings and it's
really hard for me in the UK because I
really really miss my family
um a lot of people want to know why I
came here and I came here to pursue a
pro contract
um I was actually offered one in the
fall I turned it down because honestly
um the YouTube stuff got too big but
yeah when I got to England
I was alone I missed my family I missed
my siblings and I had no friends but I
made friends with this one girl and this
is back when I just started my channel
and I really didn't have a lot in common
with the girls on my team at the time
um and I was in a long distance
relationship so it was just like it was
just hard
um but this girl really got me out of
that
um she was someone that I could talk to
someone that I could be close with and
so what we did was we went to France and
I'd never been to Paris before it was so
cool so um
we saw the Eiffel Tower
um the Mona Lisa like all the typical
France stuff and she was crying there
because her mom had been to France and
it was just like her mom had so much fun
going to France and it was just her
dream honestly to go to this place so
now fast forward when I started the
channel this girl was in a ton of my
Vlogs and we would she would see me at
the time I did a lot of random content
so I would do vlogs I would do reaction
videos and it was just whatever I wanted
to do
um but I told her I had this idea to
start my show and when I started my show
I thought that it was so cool being in
London because you know London is the
most diverse place I've ever lived like
I've been on teams with a lot of
different personalities at the time but
I've never lived in a place where I
could talk to someone from Italy to
someone from Spain to someone from
Portugal and it was just so cool so I
was like thinking we should bring
everyone together
to talk about relationships that's the
one thing who doesn't have that
who doesn't have relationships in common
so um and at the time she had come on my
show this friend and we were close she
was on the very first show
um
fast forward
a week or two
she
um
not a week or two it's actually a couple
months and this was tough on our
friendship because I just didn't have
the time I used to everything blew up so
fast everything got bigger and bigger
and bigger and I just genuinely didn't
know what to do I mean how do you handle
extreme Fame at 26 there's no book of
how to do that and you know I was just
saying my opinions and I would go on
my story and I had a I had a story one
day a Instagram story and it said modern
women want to be victims now what was my
point of this
I kept having girls come on the show and
claim they were abused but had no
evidence
and they would say they or they wouldn't
talk about how their boyfriend hit them
first and they were very deceptive and
misleading and what I realized is a lot
of these women want to be victims it
doesn't mean all women it doesn't mean
100 of women but a lot of these women
don't care about the truth they just
want to be victims and that's what I was
talking about but this friend took it
personally
she was so mad at me she couldn't stand
it
and she said to me
um I can't be your friend anymore after
those comments and I and I was sad guys
you know at the time I was in America I
was collabing I was doing all this stuff
and she messaged me this and I was so
sad because I had no other friends
and I was so lonely
do you know what it's like to be in
another country where you know no one
and
everybody that you talk to is trying to
get something from you especially the
more famous you get because everyone is
always trying to get more money from you
everybody's trying to get more you know
clout off of you and it's really hard to
see us who has good intentions and who
doesn't but this girl was there from the
beginning so I thought she had my back
but it turns out she didn't
until a month later she came back and
she said
Pearl you were right
I'm sorry
I freaked out
and she started to come around to a lot
of the ideas that I had
now don't get me wrong she's nowhere
near a conservative and I am nowhere
close to a feminist but it really showed
that even though we're on opposite ends
of the spectrum you can really work
through things and talk about them
now
now that we are friends again
um we
everything was back to normal right and
why wouldn't it be but you know there's
always that level of
will things go back to the way they were
and for the most part they did she
started to come on the channel again she
started to hang out again
um and then she went on the show one day
and she sat next to someone named Sarah
Sarah sorry Sarah Sarah
and Sarah
was a really interesting girl
I mean
this person
came on the show
and
really agreed with my friend
in the beginning but what was
interesting was that now my friend
disagreed with her
and that is the truth about
Sarah
and that's the story guys
um I know I know
um you might might have thought this was
just a random story but it did have
anything it did have stuff to do with it
so yeah she came back on the show one
day she sat next to someone named Sarah
and that's the story so that's the truth
about Sarah
[Music]
um
yeah they sat next to each other on the
show so guys um thank you for watching
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel and I'll talk to you next
time
[Music]
at the end you should do like my my
bloopers today I'm going to tell you the
truth about I can't do without laughing
okay
what up sorry
um
today I'm gonna be telling you the truth
about Sarah
got that cut that work okay